HAPPENED IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE TO ME.
DISAPPOINTED WHEN THEY COULDN'T
GET THE PRESIDENT'S DOCTOR TO
SAY HE WASN'T IN GOOD HEALTH
PHYSICALLY AND MENTALLY.
I WAS GLUED TO THIS ALL
AFTERNOON.
THE PRESIDENT'S DOCTOR CAME OUT
AND GAVE THAT GUY A CLEAN BILL
OF HEALTH.
THE FACT THAT THEY GAVE SPECIFIC
DETAILS ABOUT HIS DIET,
KNOW?
>> Greg: IT IS CORY BOOKER WHO
NEEDS A COGNITIVES            CG
NEEDS A COGNITIVES            CI
NEEDS A COGNITIVES            CE
NEEDS A COGNITIVES            CA
NEEDS A COGNITIVES            CM
NEEDS A COGNITIVES            C.
THE BEST PART WAS REPORTERS
GRILLING THIS GUY ABOUT DIET AND
EXERCISE.
HAVE YOU SEEN A REPORTER
THE DISHEVELED GUY IN THE BACK.
HE WAS ASKING ABOUT CHOLESTEROL.
DON'T GET THIS.
NO PILATES, NO MEDITATION, NO
ORGANIC KALE.
HE EATS WHAT'S IN FRONT OF THEM,
USUALLY COVERED IN KETCHUP.
BUT HE'S HEALTHIER THAN A YOGA
HE MIGHT BE LIKE THIS FOREVER
BUT THAT HE MIGHT DROP.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THESE KINDS OF
PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T DO WHAT YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO.
THEY DO WHAT THEY WANT.
>> Jesse: HE EATS WHATEVER HE
WANTS AND HE DOESN'T EXERCISE
EXCEPT WHEN HE PLAYS GOLF,
KIMBERLY.
DOESN'T SMOKE TOBACCO, NEVER
THE DOCTOR ACTUALLY SAYS IF HE
HADN'T EATEN ALL THIS
McDONALD'S IS WHOLE LIFE, HE
COULD'VE BEEN 200 YEARS OLD AND
STILL BEEN KICKING.
HE'S GOT GREAT STAMINA.
HE BARELY SLEEPS.
FOUR DO FIVE HOURS PER DAY.
HEALTH AND PHYSICAL CONDITION
IS.
HE LOVES TO PLAY GOLF.
HE HAS A VERY GOOD GENETIC
COMPOSITION IN TERMS OF HE'S
ABLE TO ENJOY GOOD HEALTH AND
PEOPLE.
NOW HE HAS THE ADDITIONAL PROOF
TO BACK IT UP.
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE THE IMPORTANT THING IS HE
DOESN'T DRINK ALCOHOL AND HE'S
NOT SMOKING.
I THINK THAT PROBABLY HELPED HIM
A LOT.
>> Jesse: ABSOLUTELY.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT
I THINK IT WAS OBVIOUSLY TO PUT
TO REST A LOT OF THE COMMENTARY
FROM THE PRESS ABOUT HIS MENTAL
FACULTIES.
THEY GAVE HIM THE HARDEST LEVEL
AND HE SCORED 30 FOR 30.
DOES IT PUT TO REST THE CLAIM
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS MENTALLY
UNFIT?
>> Dana: THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO COME TO THE
THINGS HE    THEY HATE THAT HE'D
THINGS HE    THEY HATE THAT HE'I
THINGS HE    THEY HATE THAT HE'G
HE IS DOING THEM WITH HIS FULL
THERE AS LONG AS IT TOOK TO
ANSWER ALL OF THEIR QUESTIONS SO
THEY COULDN'T SAY THEY GOT
STONEWALLED ON ANYTHING.
HE'S AN EXCELLENT HELP.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WAS, HOW
COULD IT POSSIBLY BE THAT HE IS
IN SUCH GOOD HEALTH.
ONE OF THE THINGS IS GENETICS
CERTAINLY BUT I DO THINK THERE
IS SOMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT
IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
FOLKS THAT ARE ABLE TO DO THAT
IN THEIR LIFE, THEY END UP BEING
PRETTY HEALTHY.
MITT ROMNEY WAS LIKE THAT, AND I
THINK I WILL NOT --
>> Greg: NAME ANOTHER ONE.
>> Dana: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
43.
HE DRANK UNTIL HE WAS 40 AND
PHYSICAL, THEY OBSESSED OVER HOW
MANY CIGARS DID HE SMOKE.
THAT WAS GOING TO BE THE ISSUE
THAT WOULD MAKE YOU NOT BE ABLE
TO BE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: THE MYTH ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S UNFITNESS MENTALLY
HAS BEEN BUSTED BY THE
WHITE HOUSE DOCTOR.
>> Juan: IT WAS EIGHT
COGNITIVE EXAM, NOT A
PSYCHOLOGICAL EXAM.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN SAYING OH,
ALL THE NARCISSISM, THE
IMPULSIVENESS, THAT'S NORMAL.
NEVER NARCISSISTIC AT ALL, RIGH
RIGHT?
>> Greg: BEING A JERK, IN YOUR
OPINION --
>> Jesse: I COULD TALK ABOUT
THIS ALL DAY.
>> Juan: HE DID WELL ON THIS
EXAM AND YOU SHOULD GIVE HIM
MORE CREDIT IS DUE BUT I THINK
BY THE WAY, GREGORY, I EXERCISE
AND TRY TO EAT WELL.
>> Greg: THAT'S YOUR PROBLEM.
>> Juan: I THINK THE BIG
PROBLEM IS SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
DRINKING, NOT SMOKING, NOT DOING
ANYTHING SOMEHOW IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT IS SENDING OUT
THESE OFFENSIVE TWEETS.
THAT MIGHT BE THE NEWS.
TO ME, HE'S IN GOOD HEALTH AND
THAT SHOULD BE ACKNOWLEDGE BUT I
THINK THE REPORTERS HAD EVERY
RIGHT TO ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT,
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THIS GUY
WHO EATS McDONALD'S AND
BEHAVES IN THIS WAY.
TRYING TO GET SOME UNDERSTANDING
MEDICAL CONDITION.
EFFECTIVE BOSSES, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO LIKE THEM.
YOU CAN BE A JERK.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE A JERK
DOCTOR WHO SAVES MY KIDS LIFE
THAN A CHARMING DOCTOR WHO LETS
THAT WAS A COGNITIVE EXAM, NOT A
PSYCHIATRIC ONE.
JUAN WASN'T WATCHING IT BUT YOU
CAN PREDICT THIS.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE SOME SOUND
FROM THE REPORTERS ASKING ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Reporter: CAN YOU ASSESS
THE ASSESS THE PRESIDENTS MENTAL
FITNESS?
WE ARE GOING TO DO A COGNITIVE
EXAM.
WELL ON IT.
>> Reporter: THE PRESIDENT
APPEARED TO SLUR HIS WORDS
RECENTLY.
DID YOU LOOK INTO WHAT THE CAUSE
OF THAT MIGHT'VE BEEN.
>> WE CHECKED EVERYTHING OUT.
EVERYTHING WAS NORMAL.
>> Reporter: SUGGESTED THAT
QUESTION ASKED TO GO HE DOES NOT
HAVE ANY DENTURES OR PARTIALS OF
ANY KIND.
HE IS FIT FOR DUTY.
THE REMAINDER OF THIS TERM AND
POSSIBLY ANOTHER TERM.
>> Reporter: EXPLAINED TO ME
HOW A GUY WHO EATS McDONALD'S
AND FRIED CHICKEN AND DIET COKE
AND NEVER EXERCISES IS IN AS
GOOD AS SHAPE AS HE IS.
>> IT'S CALLED GENETICS.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE GREAT GENES.
I HAVE TOLD THE PRESIDENT IF HE
HAD A HEALTHIER DIET OVER THE
LAST 20 YEARS HE MIGHT LIVE TO
BE 200 YEARS OLD.
>> CLINICIANS HAVE SAID THEY
HAVE SEEN SYMPTOMS IN THIS
>> THEY SHOULDN'T BE MAKING
THOSE ASSESSMENTS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT UNLESS THEY KNOW HIM
AND HAVE EXAMINED HIM.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE RESPONSE.
GREAT GENES.
THE DENTURE, YOU LIKE.
SEEMS LIKE HE IS SLURRING ONE
TIME.
THE DOCTOR SAID HE PRESCRIBED
SUDAFED.
>> Dana: YEAH, WE LOOKED INTO
IT, AN ANOMALY.
NOT A BIG DEAL.
ONE OF THE RUMORS, MAYBE IT'S
THE WHITE HOUSE ABOUT THAT.
I WOULDN'T, AND I DON'T CARE.
THAT'S CLARIFIED NOW.
THE PRESIDENT DOES NOT HAVE
DENTURES.
>> Greg: MY FAVORITE QUESTION
WAS THE BRITISH REPORTER WHO
ASKED THE DOCTOR OF TRUMP ASKED
THE DOCTOR HOW HE COULD BE AS
>> Jesse: OBAMA, THE 10-POUND
WEIGHTS AT THE GYM.
RUMORED TO BE SMOKING.
JUAN, THE PRESIDENT CALLED FOR
THE COGNITIVE TEST, AND HE GOT
IT.
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME A
COGNITIVE TEST WAS EVER ISSUED
TOWARDS A SITTING PRESIDENT.
DO YOU FEEL NOW BETTER ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
>> Juan: GOOD NEWS ABOUT HIS
HEALTH.
>> Jesse: GOOD NEWS.
YOU SHOULD BE HAPPY ABOUT.
>> Juan: I'M HAPPY ABOUT IT.
HE IS MY PRESIDENT TOO.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT DO YOU
SAY?
LET'S SAY HE IS TOTALLY INSANE
AND HE'S IN GOOD HEALTH.
HE HAS NO EXCUSES.
OH, MY GOSH.
>> Jesse: THE MOST AMUSING
PART, THE DOCTOR SAID SOMETIMES
I HAVE TO GET THE FIRST LADY
INVOLVED WHEN HE NEEDS TO TAKE
HIS PILLS.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S KIND OF
SWEET, ISN'T IT?
HUSBANDS AND WIVES DO THAT AND
HELP EACH OTHER OUT.
>> Jesse: WE ALL WANT THEM TO
BE HEALTHY.
>> Greg: MY WIFE DOESN'T DO
THAT TO ME.
SHE TRIES TO GET ME TO EAT MORE
CHEESEBURGERS.
>> Jesse: WHEN 43 CHOKED ON
THE PRETZEL AND PASSED OUT AND
HIT HIS HEAD AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
HOW SCARY OF A MOMENT WAS THAT?
>> Dana: I WAS NOT A PRESS
OFFICE PERSON THEN.
I WAS IN A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT A FRIEND OF MINE
WILD.
BUT THAT WAS PRETTY SCARY.
I ASKED MY MOM, I WAS TELLING
HER ABOUT IT, SHE SAID MY
BIGGEST FEAR IS CHOKING WHEN I'M
ALONE AND NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT IT
AND I DIE.
MOM, THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
THEN THAT EPISODE HAPPENED WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
OBVIOUSLY HE WAS TOTALLY FINE
AND THEN TWO WEEKS LATER,
"6 FEET UNDER," THAT HAPPENS AS
A KEY EPISODE.
>> Greg: ALSO SEX AND THE CITY
CITY.
ABOUT A PRESIDENT'S HEALTH, IT
SHOULD BE A ONE-DAY STORY.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING THAT
QUESTIONS.
A LOT OF THESE QUESTIONS WERE
PERPETUATED BY THE DOCTOR'S NOTE
THAT HE RELEASED DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.